it's time for roses and Rose a I'm
wearing red oh this girl abs is sweating
and so am I welcome to hometowns
everybody
it was another wonderful episode Monday
night of The Bachelorette and we're here
to talk about it by wonderful I mean fun
but also really really painful but a
good lesson but so hard but you know
some laughs and some kisses but also a
lot of Tears and so that's where we're
headed we're waiting for James Dean to
show where is the table at yep
so rachel is in hometowns you guys which
means she's going to do that run jump
wrap thing that's a lot so drink every
time she does it okay first eric is from
Baltimore it's kind of scary when a cell
does right here yeah and Eric purring
like a Catalan but then his family is
really cool oh my god is an first black
Bachelorette so how are you dealing with
that what a queen just lovely and bubbly
and so wonderful and Rachel should take
her everywhere she goes from now on and
just let her consult on all the dates
she can be the advisor oh my god in our
group dancing so cute you know my god
this was sure of a kind of painful but
sort of healing discussion with his
mother is life
what doesn't hurt right
hello in the toast I've been running
from love my whole life laughs great
toast a toast to Eric's family and their
great hope and I'm not running no more
motto my god then he didn't quite say I
love you I really love this girl what I
mean by that if I really care about you
he didn't enums quick get out there like
I care about your well-being I care
about what she did I forget about what
you are know and that's a bad sign for
Eric very dangerous to not at least say
I'm falling in love with you on the
hometown guys and that's what tonight's
going to be really all about is now that
it's down to it to these final four who
is really telling Rachel I am serious
about you we'll get to that floor later
I like Eric I really do you know he's
come a long way from get my name out
your mouth my man was in your mouth and
he great brian is from Miami and I was
hoping to hear the Will Smith song more
but I'm guessing that was a cost issue
so instead we got these 80s vibes while
rachel was talking there's something
sexy about it okay and Rachel is saying
Miami is sexy and then Brian takes her
to played Domino's so she can see the
real Miami take me back to the fake
Miami I want the Wilson of music video
Miami that's what I want
[Music]
I don't want to play dominoes Brian okay
oh and drink every time you see this
clear umbrella because that umbrellas
getting more time with Rachel than these
guys are okay clear
just like I like my water downloaded but
Brian and his own grey shirt did take
Rachel dancing and you know what I like
a guy who can dance
and I have to say just like this episode
made me like Eric even more it made me
like Bryan even more he talked pretty
much for the first time about things
other than how much he likes Rachel the
real man like real conversations you
know the stuff of relationship and it
was like oh I also really like Bryan
because of his mom group hug Bryan mom
you guys so what do we started she is
having a drink she is causing she is
crying she is reading Rachel and she is
telling it like it is and I could see in
her eye
that she's a good person this woman is
giving a soap opera realness if she's
happy and copy if not okay she has to be
happy
it's beyond reality TV it is the reality
of a soap opera Miami life and I just
loved her don't remember her name
Oh Olga I just did Wow still got stuff
going on up there no she the one so and
she just really loved Brian and she
knows that the she made with more than
hope it'll be his mark like a lot okay
like its life or death with this lady
right on
okay Brian love Rachel
Brian I love you so let's remember that
Peter is from Madison Wisconsin and
middle man to this episode make Madison
Wisconsin look like a cute little place
to live I mean you know maybe a lot of
people about the population of mass in
Wisconsin is 1 million people I'm gonna
look it up before the end of it
Rachel wore gray what does this mean
Rachel wore gray to Peter's home job if
you watch roses in rows a you'll know
that I spent most of the last episode
talking about how Peter wears gray all
the time including on this episode and
Rachel wore gray and I think that means
one of two things one just that she wore
gray two more likely that she is trying
to forge a subtle connection with Peter
is not being as forthcoming with this
feeling so Rachel's like look at me I'm
wearing grey you you're wearing green we
are one Peter tell me you love me
doesn't happen what's interesting to me
you guys and I hate to speculate except
that I love to speculate I think that
we're setting I think that we're being
set up to see Peter as The Bachelor
I do because Brian is trying Rachel he
loves her and on this show in this
environment it has to be so hard to know
if the relationship is real so I don't
know I would see why you would go for
the guy who likes you
Peter just seemed so unsure and you know
but we're also made to love Peter it
treats everybody the same doesn't even
those even consider good guys really
fine look at his school friends when we
saw his funny side on this date but he
had walled up and he couldn't tell
Rachel that he really cares about her
and Caroline so that's the problem that
has to be solved you know like probably
when he's going to be the bachelor
I'm just saying reality shows don't
write themselves people think because it
I want to do that once in my life I know
you to feel the exact same Peter is
quote terrified of committing to Rachel
I have walls up for a service Rachel and
I haven't figured out when those walls
will come down Peter's mom even says
he's not ready and she is saying you not
ready so much that I don't even know
what she's saying he's not ready for is
it here's a ring and I want to propose
to you not necessarily but he's not
ready Peter says he doesn't even know
what it would take to get to the next
step this is bad I want thanks for
before refreshments but in order to get
to that next step I don't know what
that's going to take and then at the end
of it he's like I'm afraid that this may
be one of the last times is here Peter
feels right act like it you know sound
scared okay
yeah Dean is from Aspen and beans date
was a moment in bachelor history
a demon Rachel loved pop champagne and
that's about as happy-go-lucky as this
basement again so we learned that gene
is going to see his father for the first
time in about two years and kind of
blows my mind that they were both okay
with this meeting happening on reality
TV but you know maybe it's forced some
conversations and that was good and if
you had never gone on The Bachelorette
you never would have talked to his
father because Rachel was like why don't
you fight your dad and he was like do I
need to talk to my dad and she was like
we didn't grasp everything
good advice Rachel keeping it 100 so
Dean is like scared even walking up to
his house for background and gives you
missed it Dean's mother died when he was
15 and his relationship with his father
just got really bad and he feels like
his dad was not there for him after all
that she was the most amazing woman I
said to my wife okay too
I've ever experienced I mean one married
27 years I have to say Dean dad was more
loving and open than I thought he would
be from the way that Dean had described
him I thought he'd be very shut off and
that's just supposed to show you you
know that relationships are gray area
and people are not black-and-white and
people are flawed and as much as II
might have wanted that love and
protection from his father maybe as a
friend is gonna give it and that is
about all and I'm going to be able to
muster when it comes to emotion
it was tough to watch you guys being had
is really painful talk with his dad and
I think Dean does want an apology from
his dad I didn't love you so eternal
thank you love by your father's that
were you saying it wasn't as maternal as
it may be you
in hindsight needed to be and ultimately
seems dad was just like yeah I I regret
this doesn't work thanks for being here
but you guys got to go and bean told
Rachel he was falling for her and Rachel
told Dean she you're absolutely so if
we're all counting up here the only one
out of school who has not come whole
continue it Peter Peter mr. Bray
Christian Grey the man I love but the
man because his love rose ceremony and
the guys look great and Dean looks more
dapper than we've ever seen Dean to have
okay Brian Brian gets the first rose
need to say use another mission and eric
gets another rose and then an absolute
crescendo of violence leads us to the
tragic ending that Dean is sent Oh
why even Dean is like he's pretty cool
but he's like I'm confused you said he
was falling for her she said she was
falling for him Rachel I love her I love
Rachel but she did not have a really
clear she says something about how she
doesn't think Dean's ready
maybe what she really means is like
Dean's got a lot to work on in himself
and his family before he's ready for
marriage and starting his own family I'm
just saying that would make sense
I've got to stop with the advice it's
too much I can't keep doing this I'll be
emotionally drained by morning and even
Dean's eggs it was mature and you know
Dean got crap on this show in the
beginning for being the young one but he
is very wise beyond his years
he told Rachel good luck he did not have
some big breakdown three years for Dean
next week on The Bachelorette
what to come the return of the clear
umbrella vain
and ooh I might be wrong about this but
I believe this to be a sighting of the
Honorable Judge Sam a Lindsay Rachel's
dad you guys it looks like it could be
him in the teaser for next week and we
have never seen him on this reality show
or any other bachelor nation show before
if you remember he did not go to
Rachel's hometown when Nick applied
there so that's enough for me I'll be
tuning in on Monday everybody for the
final three to head to Spain and some
assistance from there and of course it
would be roses and roses a without a
shame Wow I spoke to Rachel Lindsay
earlier this morning she talked to me
about fantasies tweets about Peter but
Brian about her figures after hometowns
and about what she thinks about the fact
that Peters high school yearbook photo
somebody wanted to be the bachelor yes
I'm just saying you guys did dreams come
true they do on
bachelor so let's finish our drink to
Dean's bowtie into going out like a
classy act
I just looked so not classy doing that
typical guys thanks so much for watching
please like ET on Facebook subscribe to
us on YouTube and you can connect with
me about all things bachelor nation on
Instagram snapchat Twitter etc have a
great night everybody
fine okay we did it I spelled that rose'
all over my face what a professional
bank